It's hard to compete with this kind of scenery in San Francisco,...
…but Uber CEO, Dara Khosrowshahi, hopes riders will also appreciate...
…the view inside the car.
One of 26,000 electric vehicles now on Uber's platform.
So, it turned out to be a great inspiration...
…both for riders but especially drivers to go out and go electric.
Uber has quadrupled its EV fleet in the U.S., Canada, and Europe in the past year...
…and plans to double it to 50,000 next year.
All part of its new product called Comfort Electric.
It's a Tesla, a PoleStar, a Ford Mach-E, these are great cars.
What is kind of the end goal of putting so many more EVs on your platform?
By 2030, we have a target to be fully electric in the U.S., Canada, and Europe.
By 2030, will a driver who is driving a gas powered vehicle...
...be allowed on your platform?
No. If we're doing our job, we're going to be all electric.
In the U.S., transportation is the single largest source...
...of planet-warming greenhouse gas emissions.
Beautiful, we have the Uber logo, I love it.
Uber is trying to slash its carbon footprint...
Hello.
How's it going?
...by incentivizing its drivers to switch to EVs.
But these are not cheap.
No, they're not cheap.
We need electric vehicles, and that cost 20, 30,000 dollars...
…versus 50 to 60,000 dollars.
Uber says it's going to spend 800 million dollars...
...to offset some costs for its drivers.
It's paying them an extra dollar for every EV trip they make...
…and providing discounts on charging.
Uber is partnering with Hertz, where drivers can now rent Teslas...
…on a weekly or monthly basis.